my main takeaway from that was different
than yours I think my main takeaway is
that we are so divided and I've lost
very close friends of mine who have been
in my house you know buddies of mine
over political disputes we've lost
co-friends co-friends yeah cool friends
so so the fact that you and I can
disagree on this and be completely cool
like that's the model right like that's
what everybody should be striving to
Emily who ultimate look dude if you if
you said listen my kids are sick I know
you're in Florida for a few days David
can't do it can you help me out dude in
one second I'd be there yeah
and does it matter to me if you think
Biden is a dribbling fool no it doesn't
matter to me at all
foreign
obviously uh you have not been on the
show since February we just checked this
February of 2019 so quite literally four
years ago this month right it's been a
while a lot to catch up on but we we
booked this thing a couple weeks ago
right and then last night was the State
of the Union Address right so let's
start let's start let's start with that
because something interesting happened I
referenced it on my show this morning on
my wrap-up show that what I see
happening in America that I think is one
of the most disturbing Trends is that
we're all watching the same script we're
all watching the same movie yeah and we
are experiencing wildly different things
seeing completely different things our
reactions are completely different
anyway I'm watching that thing thinking
this guy's a liar a fraud he's obviously
drugged these people are bringing in all
of the wrong policies it's a miracle he
hasn't fallen off the stage and knocked
the podium over I mean all of all of the
stuff and then I'm looking at you or
Twitter and you're seemingly impressed
by what's going on you seem to like him
you seem to think that it's put to bed
some of the questions about his mental
Acumen etc etc dementia and then I
thought man I cannot wait to sit with
Pete tomorrow because we're friends and
it does not matter we disagree on this
stuff but but how we could view this so
differently
and so the other context of that is
you're texting me like are you drunk
tweeting yeah well I thought you must be
drunk or you were hacked right because
you're going bite and seems sharp this
all makes sense so the I guess the the
more profound point is that we can
disagree about our perception we're
going to talk about what we perceived
but we're still buddies I'm still
sitting here we're gonna hang out like
that there's a context for our
disagreement so this is so this is what
I thought independent of the content The
Narrative that Biden is senile or he has
dementia I think that speech to me it
completely put that to rest he was sharp
he was focused and I understand he has a
teleprompter I understand he has notes
in front of him
a senile person or a person with
dementia I don't care if he's on
monafidil what provincial whatever drug
he is on I don't think he could have
delivered that performance now I'm
talking independent of content okay so
let's put content aside we can talk
about that sure so we'll do the content
and the policy thing after but putting
that aside so you're just talking about
his physical and mental ability to walk
up on that stage and read that prompter
you think that look I can't diagnose him
yeah for sure he has dementia or
Alzheimer's or something but to me he
clearly clearly has something wrong with
him and that the fact that they can prop
him up either through Adderall or a ton
of coffee or God knows what they have
whatever those drugs are I don't know
how do you view that and go well because
he had a decently cogent two hours that
overrides all of the other video of the
stammering and confusion okay shaking
hands with ghosts and things that made
me question okay two things let's take
one step back the thing that changed my
mind about Donald Trump yeah was one in
his in Trump's second debate with Biden
he clearly destroyed him in fact
sometimes I think Megan Kelly and I are
the same person she tweeted something
like uh it's all been an act because up
at that point I almost never heard him
make a coher current argument or
sentence or statement wait when you're
saying he destroyed him you mean Biden
destroyed no Trump in the second to
second because there were only two
because the first one was the first one
was not that good
but then I thought like you can't go
from nothing to that like you can't go
from a a rambling incoherent ignoramus
to that I mean he was on that I think
any objective independent Inquirer would
have looked at that debate and say Trump
so I think with Biden
so so this gets back to the question how
can two people look at I think any
independent person would look at that
and say
he was on point it was a good talk he
was clear he does not have senility he's
not suffering signality he's not to
dementia his points are well articulated
he wasn't slurring and I realized that's
a low bar
okay so some of the words weren't
articulate or enunciated perfectly but I
I walked away from that and I questioned
a lot of the narratives I also think
that there is a kind of unfairness no
matter who's in office you know you when
Biden uh pin the the and I gave blood or
something on his granddaughter people
edited it to make it look like he was
touching her breast or I think that
there's a lot of just
um hacks who if they don't like the
content and we can talk about the
concert that's first and I'm just
talking about him standing up there and
delivering that performance I don't
understand how you could not look at
that and said drugs aside
say that was that was a he was on point
I was a good talk he was clear he made
arguments he remembered to the extent
that he's on a teleprompter he was
looking around he engaged people in real
banter uh I thought it was a great talk
okay so I'm gonna content inside through
this content right so first off I would
say that a we don't know what the drug
situation is so I would imagine and I
don't know enough about cognitive the
drugs that they prescribe for cognitive
decline or whatever but it seems to me
that you could basically take almost
anyone probably unless they're at the
real end of stage with this stuff and
make them cogent for two hours so that I
don't see how that puts it to bed if
anything it seems to me you're saying
there there probably are drugs out there
that can make you okay so that would be
the question to find somebody right
again this is coming from a guy who has
brought up an ethical violation except
for Oaks papers right uh you know by the
way I prefer that you're right in a way
he is still the pilot of the plane right
so whether I agree with the stuff or not
the guy is in charge of an awful but
hoping that that I'm right doesn't make
it right like you you would have to find
people who suffered from similar
perceived cognitive ailments and give
them whatever Suite of drugs and see if
they could perform I I I I would highly
doubt it unless you want to say he's
somehow like a trick pony he somehow and
even this is territory I'm not
particularly comfortable wading into
he's somehow performatively giving a
talk he has no idea what he's talking
about but even then it was pretty
impressive I just thought it put to bed
to rest the idea that here's a senile
demented guy now now if you've watched
videos of Joe Biden from 20 years ago I
mean he's clearly a different man I mean
it's just I'll give it to you 100 but
that talk I thought he shined you know
it's interesting because I I also spent
I had two grandmothers that both had a
certain amount of dementia yeah my my
grandmother on my mom's side had it for
longer and I and I really saw and I
spent a lot of time with her because I
was doing stand-up at night so during
the days I was with her often for days
on End hours and hours and I really saw
that decline one of the things that I
noticed that Biden seems to have and
I've seen a lot of people mention this
also is uh there's a dysregulation
related to his emotional response yeah
so at times he seems very slow and quiet
then he does that whispering thing and
then out of nowhere he starts yelling oh
well you don't know why about China yeah
and that China thing where he's yelling
it's like there was no anger to be
expressing there but he he has to emote
in a very weird way because something
back there isn't all right again I'm not
a doctor it could be a performative
thing too though right I mean it could
be like this is almost as if it's broken
down and it's not performing correctly
right like well it wouldn't be
as if he wouldn't doing doing it
correctly if he broke down and had
random outbursts but if he has outbursts
about the same thing but again I don't
even think that was an outburst I think
he was trying to drill home something
maybe even to appease the Republicans I
don't know right the funny thing is
neither one of us know what he was
trying to drive hold on I lead it to the
content part of it okay so putting that
aside because I I don't want to spend
three hours talking about his cognitive
state but I think the fact that we even
don't really see that eye to eye is
interesting that that you just feel it
was enough evidence as you said to put
it to bed where to me it was was like
that's not enough evidence to put to bed
it's enough evidence to go oh I'm
probably right about this thing and we
will probably find out that I'm right
right and you know what I mean like
think about it if he makes it through
the term at some point when he's no
longer president or or if he's had to
step down or saying it's all going to
come out he's obviously on something
right so so my main takeaway for that
was different than yours I think my main
takeaway is that we are so divided and
I've lost very close friends of mine who
have been in my house you know buddies
of mine over political disputes and just
we've lost co-friends co-friends yeah
cool friends so so the fact that you and
I can disagree on this and be completely
cool like that's the model right like
that's what everybody should be striving
and who ultimate look dude if you if you
said listen my kids are sick I know
you're in Florida for a few days David
can't do it can you help me out dude in
one second I'd be there yeah
and does it matter to me if you think
Biden is a dribbling fool no it doesn't
matter to me it's actually more
interesting in a way because we're all
going into our own Echo Chambers whether
we like it or not it's becoming
increasingly hard to do it so because I
know you as a person and as a decent
human being and all that to to watch
last night and I'm watching you tweet
and I'm like right this is wild if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about Academia
check out our Academia playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell